Hello, and welcome to the Unreal Training Sequencer Animation Production Workflows.
My name is Kevin Miller, and I'm an instructor for Epic Games.
This course is one of the follow-up courses to the Sequencer Introduction Course and begins
the Sequencer Animation Track of courses.
We'll begin this course with a look at virtual production, pipelines, and workflows.
Then review some of the core concepts from the introduction courses, such as importing
animations and sequencer fundamentals.
After that, we will look at the sequencer features and tools related to animating with
Unreal Engine, such as the workflow features and tools that you can use while animating
in-engine before we dive into some hands-on animation practice where I will briefly cover
animation assembly and then walk through a step-by-step exercise on using the inverse
solve to modify animations.
Finally, we will wrap up this course with some final recommendations discussing organization,
workspace layouts, and I'll provide you with some tips and resources for continuing your
animation training with Sequencer.
Additionally, this course will also use the project SEQ9050153 from the previous courses,
and the level map should load automatically.
But if the map does not load at the launch of the project, it can be found in the Content
browser under the courses, course maps, and it is the level map titled SEQ90501 map.
Course materials for this course are located in the courses folder under the 20501 course
topics.
Once again, if you ever need to reference the location of the course map, that can be
found at the beginning of the slide deck after the training outline.
Now let's move on to our first section and begin with a discussion of virtual production
pipelines and workflows.